[Musique]
Salut matin
Téléchargement Gratuit
salut salut
le salon
Hey Kung Fu Dieu, aïe, c'est trop
confus quand mâché non seulement là
il y a beaucoup de savon
[Musique]
Salut l'animal violet résident de Yunia
Donc si on s'en occupe, c'est comme Next
La génération ne peut vraiment pas paraître grande
ce qui reflète de plus en plus ce genre d'extinction
que HC est aux commandes depuis longtemps
Nous avons presque fini avec ces œufs de tortue
perdu trois espèces et nous seulement
il ne reste qu'une seule espèce et c'est elle
Disons que si nous avons le pouvoir d'acheter ça
augmentant de jour en jour
[Musique]
Wahyu hitz.ehi mais on ne peut pas fils
En fait, il y a aussi une pénurie sur le marché
manque d'éducation et de connaissances
Je vois. Nous avons donc aussi une tâche à accomplir
faire prendre conscience aux gens que nous avons
Je n'ai pas bougé depuis longtemps
cette jurisprudence culmine
plutôt que l'absence de précipitation que
la société telle que nous la voyons
que de cet aspect faire
bouge-nous, nous voulons, nous voulons éduquer
Notre société va dans cette direction
plus progressiste dans la préservation de la nature
autour
[Musique]
salut salut